[Music]
let us begin if we can biology with
the current state of the crypto market i
know a lot of people would love to hear
your thoughts on what you're observing
and just to date this we are recording
july 1
2022 and then perhaps hearing your
thoughts on the india sphere but let's
begin with those two prompts
sure so i'm not a trader like uh you
know i'm more of a much more of a
long-term investor angel vc there's
actually a there's a fun tweet today by
a guy
travis underscore cling i've been doing
this for 46 straight months i've never
seen one like this before and he's just
got a list of all the carnage in the
markets and the thing is that carnage is
in the crypto markets but also in the in
the non-crypto markets and it is it's a
little more pronounced in crypto but it
is definitely like a systemic type of
thing and the way i kind of think about
it is there's very few spaces that i get
into where i don't have an all-weather
thesis
that works independent of the price
and so i was in genomics way before like
people were talking about genomics i was
you know doing machine learning way
before people were talking about
machining you know like it's kind of
weird
to see people talking about stuff that
you're doing like 10 or 15 or whatever
years ago not to say in a thumb chest
way but just that
you want to try to identify these things
that have value independent of that and
the fundamental value of cryptocurrency
is
can you have a system
where the root permissions are
independent of the us and chinese
establishments
that is the fundamental question is one
of digital freedom
because and i can kind of tease that out
and so on and so forth but it's
fundamentally do you actually have
property rights on the internet digital
property rights or
can somebody with a police badge
from the u.s or chinese establishment
depending on what side of the world
you're on get into all of your stuff
surveil all your stuff take all of your
stuff freeze and seize all of your stuff
and so on and so forth right so that
fundamental question of whether digital
property rights
should exist and whether they will be
valuable in the medium to long term is
what gives me confidence in the space
not the specific price
so i can talk more but that's you know
prices down prices up i would only
invest in those kinds of things that i
believe further that aspect of like
freedom and control
question for you in our first episode i
think at some point you mentioned
for someone who is not going to make a
full-time study of things
splitting their allocation to crypto and
this is not investment advice this is
two people talking for informational
purposes only but splitting 50 50
bitcoin eth does that
still hold or would you based on
what you've seen since and what you are
seeing now maybe any developing theses
change that
no i i'd say stick with that i mean
again not investment advice and so on
but basically
those ecosystems are just still
absolutely massive if you look at
as i said you know i think i said
something like
buy it and then hold it for 10 years and
let's see where we are in 10 years the
fundamentals in terms of not not just
number of users but
conversation i mean if you could if
twitter was open source or rather more
specifically if it was open state let's
say not just the source code that's
available but the back end was available
the database was available okay not just
through an api but that you could just
hit a key and see every tweet if you
wanted to every public tweet at least if
it was open state and you could plot
the number and the depth of interactions
on bitcoin and ethereum and all of their
offshoots not just those keywords but
the
thousands of keywords and memes and
communities and so on that would be
built on this these are like countries
that have built out
and you know like those are things that
just have mass to them and you can mark
them to market they've got downs and
they've got ups but they are absolutely
massive things with tens of millions of
dedicated people around the world
and they come out of nowhere so yeah i
don't believe that they're gonna go away
but again not financial advice it's just
my personal personal belief you can get
much more sophisticated than that but
like the absolute worst thing to do by
the way and this is maybe obvious but
i'll just say this is
the worst thing to do is buy an asset
when it's in the news and sell it when
it's in the news
and what you instead want to kind of do
is
like something it's all inevitable that
something will pique your attention okay
and then what you do is you set a
calendar reminder you know let's say 30
days 60 days 90 days
so that you are almost like retargeting
yourself
and then you go and you actually do
research on it outside of the scrum
right outside of people yelling about it
you intentionally do it async to the
market sentiment there's a famous
cartoon it's a guy he's like this looks
like it could be a goodbye and someone
overhears they're like bye bye bye bye
bye and then the guy's like this doc
could really excel and someone over here
sell so sell sell you know like this
right and it's this hilarious sort of
loop which you don't want to be the
current thing you're on you don't want
to be the person who is
buying high selling low and i think the
only way to not do that is set calendar
reminders assess your portfolio like
whether it's a quarterly basis or
something like that and try to make
async decisions
like you almost never want to sell on
bad news buy on good news that's my
macro outside of any given you know
specific thing yeah let me add one thing
to that which is
humans in general and i succumb to this
sometimes to over
estimate their predictive abilities so
what is very helpful is set a time it
could be once a year jan 1
jan 5 doesn't really matter
where you sit down and you identify say
i'm just picking a time frame six months
from now and you grab a bunch of
potential
asset classes or stocks or indices so
maybe it's
bitcoin
a barrel of oil
s p 500
and make your predictions and then set a
reminder to look at them
three months or six months later when
you may as you are influenced
subconsciously by
chatter on twitter
trends in the news and so on to think
that you know where things are going
let's see how successful you were over
the preceding six months so that's also
a good way to check your cognitive
biases
you